what up guys it's goes in and kitty hi
I'm saying I'll just say her name this
time yeah so guys we're talking about
John Ball super episode 47 yes it is and
now I was it was dope it was cool shows
good still some unanswered things but
that's good keeps us guessing gives us
wondering of course you don't want
everything answered in the first episode
so kind of what happened well just would
be we see Future Trunks running away
from this mysterious threat which we end
up seeing is the black Goku we've heard
like spoilers about in the community and
he just looks like Goku base evil which
is gonna be cool cuz it's gonna have the
appearance of Goku and yet it's not
gonna be like the carefree good guy it's
gonna be like some evil dude so that's
just gonna be interesting in a yeah and
I actually like his design i like his
outfit i look i love the way it looks I
don't know why he has one patara earring
in his ear but we'll see I mean we also
got an image of some kind of like
perhaps another Supreme Kai or so yeah
in the intro it was like a grain Supreme
Kai yeah bini hadal he may have only had
one so that may be alluded that they may
in defusing or something I don't know
anyways yeah I oh no I definitely like
the way the character looks I mean yeah
I thought he was gonna be some type of
super saiyan or something but I mean he
were one of the last thing is is that he
says two trunks is today is finally
gonna be the day that you die sand which
makes me wonder then perhaps he's not
what is he yeah what does he see another
churros like experiments I can see an
Android is he like something beyond cell
like we'll see like there's so much to
guess about there's also it's just so
like it's juxtaposing the whole time is
showing us like this mundane training
and situations in the earth that we know
and then just like crazy ass situations
almost like shocking actually they are
shocking and tragic situations in the
future and how these guys from the past
have
no idea what's about to come so that was
cool I was just [ __ ] man like so his
mother trunks his mother was killed she
like I turn to turn to those yeah
literally like turn to dust and then as
if like that's not bad enough my trunks
his girlfriend were led to believe like
which I like her character design okay
I'm lately well we'll get into it but
and then she's killed and it's like bro
like if Gohan dying God you super saiyan
like how the [ __ ] isn't this getting you
like angry you know like how is this not
getting that transformation out of you
he's just like oh no I gotta run into
the past like been like I don't know I
just felt like bouma alone should have
like almost instigated another
transformation let alone boma and my but
whatever that's yes i knows even what's
the transformation this guy could be
lazy close but that's not the point i
just i just don't like as a saying we
know that those situations bring about
the greatest changes any in this case we
just didn't see it yeah I don't know why
Mayan trunks are the same age because in
beggining of Dragon Ball my is a lot
older than Goku so my should go cruising
it's like late 40s early 50s and super
Marche be at least bordering mine seven
if not over sunday i don't know maybe
they used some like thing to restore
their youth or something i don't know
what's going on but I don't think yeah I
don't think so i think cuz she's small
now in present before I I don't know but
who cares like I mean I like her design
I think she's probably my favorite
female design in the show well she was
your favorite female until she got blown
up yeah she was with her female so but
yeah that sucks actually because I'm not
a big fan of my in like present timeline
but in the future one like she looks
really cool i love the shotgun that she
carries around a shotgun i think that's
a sick idea sick design
and that took is cool too but FERC yeah
there are inconsistencies but like with
my like I like the character so much
that I didn't care too bad like we got
only like 55 lies out of her yeah five
lines before she got blown to
smithereens and one pissed you off the
one about cats forget their owners face
in three days yeah yeah I like counts
okay guide to life as he's like no well
I like all animals but that's besides
the point anyways okay now on to
something else that I want to talk about
what brawl goku vegeta we sand beerus
seem to be chillin like they're best
friends all the time vajinas trying to
one-up goku by trying to train without
it and finally we know there is no one
higher than the omni king yeah so i
guess i see what's what the problem will
be kind of that day on he won't be able
to solve because it seems like the omni
King can't focus his power on like let's
say killing an individual it seems like
he's more of a like man you know you
can't blow up the universe but what that
what's good that gonna do you know he
can't save it by just killing black goku
for example so that's what I'm wondering
like if yeah it seems almost that he has
to destroy entire universe yeah it used
to be a teensy can't fight a lot yeah he
12 isn't it no no yeah what 1212
whatever you blow up sex universes which
like you wanted to comment right but
yeah and it's like um we said beerus
story says he's so much more powerful
than anybody by a large margin you know
i'm hoping this is a character day don't
find out somehow end up surpassing like
like no yeah i don't think you can like
he's pretty much like the mangaka like
no one like he has the power to erase or
create like well we don't know he's all
right but we know literally destroy like
universes like literally he has he has
the power of the writer so yeah I mean
it's almost limitless he literally blink
so no universe disappears that's exactly
word for word how they disappeared us in
a blink of
he can destroy planets galaxies and even
universes yeah so that that's cool
finally getting the conclusive evidence
of his strength and where he fits into
the dragon ball z timeline and like
strength line and yeah I'm getting
excited i still dont ill wondering why
trunks has blue hair yeah what is the
blue hair about I'm not I'm not sure yet
like I hope like but he it seems to be
his like go to basic form so now
wondering is it because he's found a way
where that super saiyan blue becomes his
base or are they somehow now recreating
the character to have bomas hair color
instead of the old purple but that
wouldn't make sense because kids trunks
is still purple i will i'm looking
forward to that being explained because
like you know i'm wondering why the [ __ ]
is his hair for ya and you know it's
interesting they said a line is he said
earlier that goku can also sense a
meeting like this guy is evolving and
like what's going on we know he's not a
sin but i'm curious what is he like what
oh yeah we'll see but what pisses me off
is why did trunks was a sword man like
is he gonna be like now without a sword
like that's as soon as sure thing see
like I'm just I'm just worried that like
they're gonna take what was awesome
about future trunks and kind of uh take
away like the awesomes bunch yeah so
we'll see like I feel like he better get
a sword on earth because that guy needs
a sword you should have a solar if he's
gonna end up training with beers and we
used to like that's another interesting
thing it's like early I they have to
write I think I think they're all gonna
train together and I can't wait I can't
wait to see people on equal footing or
at least around the same manner because
we were saying like all finally Goku and
Vegeta are the same now they're throwing
in another saying who's probably gonna
be was probably going to be the same so
it's gonna be it's going to be sick to
see so many sayings pushing each other
and around the same level yeah well I
don't know how close they are two beers
but i still think with the little
in a vegeta sparring with we stand we is
taunting him that he can't let the hit
on him I don't think that we smite be
level a few levels above them we
definitely hands yeah there's no doubt
about it Wiese is and worried what we
think about the earth stuff in general
just comic relief just wore your
thoughts on that you mean when they're
picking cabbages sure yeah it was pretty
funny in a sons like how he wrote
piccolo into life and then he's like
leaves and then Crillon just comes
across yeah and chichi ropes Crillon
into doing it thats hilarious just like
i'm pissed off that she she keeps like
pushing education academia on her
children like go go hon okay well like
go ten like he has less academic
aspirations then go on so i don't
get--why like even he is roped into that
like yeah they gotta give up on the
snowflake in their in their world and
their universe is like education seems
to be the one take a backseat to
everything else that's going on because
in their world in their universes their
guardians of you know protecting
everything that's good like the heat
this should be full Goku should be
focused on training the next generation
data or it's almost funny it's like it's
like a metaphor for perhaps even even
Toriyama because everybody was saying
it's all about education it's all about
education focus on the wrong thing and
then he also just did this other thing
which actually changed worlds and change
people's lives and even created a world
and it's he's pretty much kind of saying
like there are people we don't even know
his relationship with his mother but
there are people who will want you to
focus on what society thinks is awesome
I want society thinks is great but then
when you take a look at the big picture
if goku didn't save the world all those
times nobody could go to university
education look at runk future how
important is that
okay sure for them so it kind of goes to
show how really sometimes people forget
to put things in perspective and see
what's actually important in the big
picture yeah cuz you guys got to
remember to Earth's been blown up twice
now it's been blown up by Kidd Boone has
been blown up by golden Frieza and both
times you know education isn't going to
save the world in this situation because
I don't know it's it's it's if it's the
thing for you it's the right thing but
you know Legos and says you got to put
some things in perspective first that's
my salt in conclusion guys we're excited
we want to see what happens next I I'm
gonna miss my it's very unfortunate now
I guess we're not going to see her until
the end of the arc again which is kind
of sucks cuz I liked her but whatever
and was the [ __ ] not even this year no I
feel like that's the thing we're gonna
have to talk about the timelines like
I'm guessing to come back before they
die I don't know if if this world goes
by worldline theory or just one world
line so that if they change the past
they change the future perhaps that's
it's gonna be fun to explore Toriyama
version of time travel well I don't know
if it's gonna happen because I think
about in the cell games they killed and
actually didn't kill 17 and 18 that's
never mind in the series I Gohan was
told that he I believe so yeah we'll see
the hot the something we'll have to
change definitely yeah but and then we
saw the blue liquid which was referenced
before wasn't it was boma was working on
that right I think so no oh in our prior
episode she was working in slowly yes
finally it seems like that's gonna be
the way he gets better they finally put
explain that please we were wondering
what that blue stuff she was working on
was and now we know all right guys kid
Kai is gonna finish up now yeah okay so
the thing is I'm going to give this up
so like an eight and a half nine because
it makes me very excited it had to like
dramatic scenes with like him killing my
and
even more so killing boma you know it
gets me hyped I love the character it's
exciting we finally broken the filler
episodes you know that you know what
this whole arc has huge huge huge
potential and I hope they maximize it I
hope they don't make drunk so silly weak
character like kind of what they did
with Vegeta and stuff like that but yeah
I'm super excited overall like I said
eight and a half nine and yeah can't
wait for the next one yeah I won't even
read it I'll just like you know I wanna
do that i'll just say i'm excited i
thought it was good and i'll see you
guys next week bye see you later space
cowboys